[Applause]
thank you very much you know appropo of
what Mike was saying about the threat to
the freedom of speech that is very real
and people don't realize just how
severely threatened it is and uh as a
matter of fact Mike is quite right on
October 11th I have to turn into Regner
publishing the manuscript of my next
book which will be called the complete
infidels guide to free speech and its
enemies and that could be my last one
because if uh the Democratic candidate
is elected on and becomes president on
January 20th uh she has a very very
lengthy record of opposing the freedom
of speech working with the organization
of Islamic cooperation to restrict it
and to find ways around the first
amendment one of the most ominous things
that has happened over the last few
years uh in a year uh years full of
ominous developments has been the
increasing common usage of a phrase that
you may have heard and if you have not
yet heard it you certainly will hear it
in the near future and that is hate
speech is not free speech as if there
were an objectively
quantifiable concept of hate speech that
everyone can agree upon and that does
not deserve first amendment protection
when actually one man's hate speech is
another man's uncomfortable truth and
the label hate speech is used nowadays
to stigmatize and marginalize honest
discussion about the Jihad threat in
many other issues and if that initiative
succeeds and this is deemed hate speech
and uh not reward not to be given first
amendment protection then that's
effectively the end of the first
amendment altogether and whoever decides
what hate speech is will be able
thereafter to set the limits of the
political discourse and completely rule
us out of
it by means of calling it calling what
we're saying hate speech and so that is
a very important issue in this present
campaign that has been very lightly
touch touched upon but I digress because
I'm here to talk about something even
more unpleasant and that's Iran and so
in terms of
Iran it's not so much in the headlines
of course today we did hear that uh
there was a secret de yet another secret
deal to give $400 million to Iran that
was actually airlifted over in unmarked
cargo planes it was clearly something
that the Obama Administration knew was
wrong and unethical and nonetheless went
ahead as they have with this entire Iran
nuclear deal but uh I must tell you at
this time that Iran is a greater threat
although less flashy and less headline
grabbing than Isis or the Islamic State
it is in the long run much more
dangerous and of course this is in part
because Isis looks at Iran and it sees
Iran as what it wants to be when it
grows up the Islamic State or Isis
controls a territory and is enforcing
Islamic law there of course they are
sunnis and Iran is Shiite but otherwise
there are more similarities than
differences Iran enforces Islamic law
Iran
is just as Draconian and authoritarian
totalitarian in fact and stringent in
its application of Islamic law with all
the stonings and the amputations and all
the rest of it as Isis but Iran is an
established nation state with a great
history and with an established military
and with an
international network of Terror
organizations at the center you know I'm
sure that you have been to if if you've
been to other Center events and you have
read Center Publications by Me by David
har by Daniel Greenfield by Jamie glazov
you have seen a great deal about how
leftists work with Islamic supremacists
and Sharia supremacists and they are
completely in league and in line in in
what strikes many as an unlikely
Alliance but actually is a is a
completely understandable Alliance when
you understand that they're both
totalitarians both wanting to impose an
Earthly Paradise by Force of Arms by by
by violence whenever the far-left takes
power there's a reign of terror and what
the reign of terror is in service of is
the paradise of economic equality and
the the workers Paradise as the Soviet
Union was called and how what do you do
with those who get out of line well of
course you kill them the Sharia law
works exactly the same way it's
enforcing it is the law of God the
perfect law for human beings and it
establishes a paradig on Earth if it's
implemented this is in the Islamic view
of course that if you establish Islamic
law that's the way the world is supposed
to work it's the paradisal state and of
course what do you do with those who get
out of line you cut off their heads you
cut off their hands or you Stone them to
death or whatever both of them the
Communist and the Islamic vision of what
the world ought to be like is a
procrustean bed you remember procrustes
the uh ancient Greek Tyrant who had he
he had a bed and you had to lie in it if
you were his enemy and if you were too
small for it he would stretch you out
and if you were too too tall for it he
would cut off whatever was necessary to
make you fit and that is like Sharia or
like the farle and the Iranian
government the Islamic Republic of Iran
the most Islamic government in the world
aside from Saudi Arabia is working with
podos which is a Spanish Pol political
party a left far-left political party
that is secular and wants to do all the
things that far- leftists want to do
when they get into Power that's the
convergence and they are working with
his Bala of course and Hamas which is
Sunni many people have said for example
that uh they didn't you may you may
recall Omar matin the uh shooter in the
gay nightclub in Orlando Florida and he
was known to the police and he was known
to the FBI and they had questioned him
and they said that they let him go and
they didn't think he was a threat you
know why because he didn't know enough
about Islam that's what they thought now
these are the people who say Islamic
terrorism has nothing to do with Islam
so we're talking about very dim bulbs to
start with but then he what happened was
this is not a degression Omar matin he
had praised his balah and Al-Qaeda and
claimed to be members of both his Bala
is Shiite it's a wholly owned and
operated subsidiary of the Islamic
Republic of Iran Al-Qaeda is Sunni
sunnis and Shiite Shia hate each other
and so the feds thought Omar matin
doesn't know what he's talking about
he's just some nut because if he knew
about Islam like we do he would know
that sunnis and Shia hate each other and
he couldn't possibly be a member of both
a Sunni and a Shiite Terror
organization well in reality the Islamic
Republic of Iran funds Hamas which is
Sunni and funds his Bala which is
Shiite the Islamic Republic of Iran is
Shiite they're only 10 to 15% of Muslims
worldwide but the Islamic Republic
because it has Global pretentions is
funding sunnis including Al-Qaeda and
the Taliban in an attempt to become the
world
leader of Islam the Islamic leader the
leader of the Islamic
world and that includes the sunis
there's an old Arabic proverb that
translates my brother against my brother
but both of us against our cousin the
Islamic Republic of Iran epitomizes that
because they will happily work with
sunnis who persecute Shia and hate them
and have killed them for centuries
against non-muslims who they hate even
more especially
Jews so we have a country that Obama has
just given hundreds of billions of
dollars to that in every mosque on
Friday you know Friday is the big day
the for Muslim
they go to the mosque on at noon and
they hear a sermon uh and that is the
the most important day to go to the
mosque and every Friday in the mosque
it's ordered by the Islamic Republic of
Iran every mosque in Iran they chant
death to America and death to Israel
well I know that's very much like what
you do in your church or synagogue but
nonetheless it is a manifestation of a
very deep hatred that
that is one that obviously the Obama
Administration is completely discounting
and not taking seriously in the
slightest John krey was confronted about
the death to America chance right after
the nuclear deal was concluded and he
said uh well you know they don't really
have any concrete plan to destroy
America so this is not a matter of
concern well as a matter of fact there
are numerous is Iranian authorities who
have said that they welcome war with the
United States they are working toward
war with the United
States and they believe they can win it
because they are not pursuing it as a
conventional War they are pursuing it as
by means of subversion and
infiltration so if you think back think
think of the whole picture now that you
have the Islamic Republic that has just
gotten several hundred billion dollars
from the United States in sanctions
relief what do they do they fund a
Global Network of terrorists and leftist
political organizations who will get
this money exactly those
organizations that is something that the
Obama Administration has also lied to
the American people about they said they
actually there were statements from
Obama administration officials several
months ago saying the the Iranian
military is very annoyed because they're
not getting any of the sanctions money
and it's all going to improve the
economic situation of Iranian citizens
that was an out andout lie as a matter
of fact his balah and Hamas have
received immense boosts in their budget
courtesy Barack Obama and John KY and
none of this money is going to improve
the lot of Iranian citizens it is all
going to the military and to the
terrorist organizations meanwhile hisbah
you've no doubt heard of hisbah they are
right at the North of Israel they have
vowed repeatedly to destroy Israel they
are working to do so they say that next
the next one the next war with Israel is
really going to be the one but of course
they've said this before nonetheless
they have very sophisticated Weaponry
they'll have more of it because of
Barack Obama and John Carrey and they
need to be taken seriously but they're
not just in Lebanon another place that
they are notably around the world is in
northern Mexico and they are in northern
Mexico because they are training the
drug cartels in kidnapping and beheading
and learning meanwhile profiting from
the drug cartels whom they are
instructing to finance their own
operations now the point is not just to
deal drugs in Mexico the point is to get
across the border into the United States
and of course that's not a very
difficult thing to do as long ago as
nine years ago there was an FBI official
who said that there were already his
Bala sleeper cells in the United States
now why haven't we heard about about his
Bala sleeper
cells doing acts of terrorism because
they have
voluntarily opted not to pursue that
route Isis does that and Isis is a very
serious threat and it certainly grabs
all the attention when it carries out
these Lone Wolf Terror attacks by people
inspired by it or who consider
themselves to be under its Authority as
the caliphate but Iran is up to
something else the FBI uh Observer who
was watching these sleeper cells he said
that they were not going to commit
Terror attacks in the United States
because that would attract too much law
enforcement
attention and ended up hampering their
activities and they were getting what
they wanted without them so well that
they didn't need to resort to that kind
of
thing now getting what they wanted in
terms of what what do you think they
were talking about it seems to me that
one of the primary manifestations
of them getting what they wanted was the
Iran deal itself that they were able to
convince the enough people in the
administration that this would be a good
thing whoever it was who convinced them
we know that Ben rhods Obama's top
foreign policy adviser has admitted to
lying to the American people about the
deal that not only did they lie about
where the money went but Ben rhods also
has admitted that they lied about the
nature of the Iranian government they
said this is this new president ruhani
who replaced mmud akad you remember akad
he was very flashy he was very uh
flamboyant you could say he he he uh G
gained a lot of attention with his
bellicose and and and arrogant
statements ruhan is much more subtle
much more in the background and so Ben
rhods hasn't has said that they
portrayed him as a moderate and were
telling the American people that this
agreement was with moderate elements of
the Iranian regime that they could work
with and would bring Iran back into the
harmonious family of Nations it was all
a lie ruhani is not moderate ruhan is no
different look you you can't be
president of Iran and be moderate the
supreme leader of Iran the Ayatollah K
he chooses all the presidential
candidates that makes for a very narrow
political Spectrum even more narrow than
we have in the United States between the
mainstream Republicans and the Democrats
this is very very narrow and if he was
allowed to run for president he's not a
good
man so someone must have told Ben rhods
someone must have prevailed upon the
people who are making the decisions in
the Obama Administration somebody must
have convinced them that this was a good
thing to do that it was a wise choice to
try to empower Iran and that it would
stabilize the Middle East and the world
to do so somebody must have convinced
them of that I don't know who and I am
not in the least talking about any kind
of conspiracy theory or something like
that you may recall that in 2012 the
Harper government in Canada closed down
the Iranian Embassy in Ottawa why did
they do that they did that because they
had widespread evidence
of Terror activity and Espionage being
committed from the embassy being being
planned and carried out from the embassy
now Iran has no Embassy in Wasington but
we would be naive to think that it
doesn't have a
presence and they are working toward
they getting what they want this is the
most this deal is the most disastrous
agreement that any Administration has
ever entered into with any foreign
government and the details of it are so
ludicrous that when I tell them to you
you will think well that really can't be
so this really could not possibly be
this bad but you may recall prime
minister Benjamin Netanyahu said that
after the deal was concluded he said the
deal allows for 24 days notice for the
inspectors to come in and that's you
know imagine if you gave that to drug
dealers that would be a lot of time for
them to flush all the meth down the
toilet and be completely clear Netanyahu
said that and was widely ridiculed for
it but it's actually quite it's it's a
readily demonstrable fact it's right in
the joint comprehensive plan of action
which is the name of the ARA Ian deal
it's readily available you can read it
uh online or you can read it in the book
The Complete infidels guide to Iran and
it gives 24 days notice you the before
any inspection can carry out be carried
out first there's the complaint and then
there has to be uh seven days before the
complaint is answered and if the
complaint is not answered satisfactory
then there's another seven days before
some the next stage and it all adds up
to 24 days before anybody can go in and
then who can go in not Americans
Americans are barred from inspecting the
sites Canadians too for that matter so
who can go in well if the Islamic
Republic of Iran has plenty of friends
around the world and I have no doubt
that anybody who ends up actually
inspecting those nuclear sites if they
are foreigners at all will be from
friendly States who will tell tell us
that everything is okay but notice I
just said if they are foreigners at all
and that is because the most ludicrous
aspect of this deal is that Iran gets to
inspect its own sites
and then tell us that everything is
okay and it's not a joke it's
true this was one of the other secret
aspects of this deal I expect that there
probably going to be more that will come
out in the next year or so showing that
even more was
given this
is not just mismanagement this is not
just bumbling and making mistakes this
is a treasonous act this is empowering a
country that wants to have war with the
United
States empowering an enemy State and
there is no minimizing that there is no
denying that or or sugarcoating it the
reality of this deal is that an avowed
enemy of the United States one that
repeatedly confronts this is another
thing that has just come out recently do
you remember when those Sailors were
captured and do you remember the
cognitive
dissonance between the reality and the
statements coming from the
administration that Joe Biden said oh
this was a strictly routine matter the
boats drifted off course they drifted
their navigation equipment failed and
they accidentally ended up in Iranian
Waters and the Iranians were very
helpful in getting them back and
meanwhile the Iranians have them with
their hands behind their backs and
blindfolded that's how you treat
prisoners of
War but not only that it recently has
come out that the US Navy is confronted
on a more or less daily basis daily in
the Persian Gulf by the Iranian Navy
they are aggressively
pursuing war and they are in the Persian
Gulf trying to establish and reinforce
the idea that they are the ones in
charge and they have and they they
actually have said this explicitly that
they the Americans know what lines they
must not cross they're not allowed to
cross
in the Persian Gulf and of course Obama
wants to cement his legacy by bringing
peace to the the the Middle East and the
World by this Iran deal so he's not
going to confront them he's not going to
do answer their provocations in any way
but that only reestablishes and
reinforces the image of the United
States as weak and pusillanimous and
able to be pushed around very easily and
Iranians the Iranians are getting
increasingly boastful about that and
there was recently a top Islamic
revolutionary guards General who said
that if the if the Americans cross those
lines we will chase them back to the
Gulf of
Mexico empty boasting
right well maybe but what if they do get
the nuclear weapons there's nothing
really stopping them now do you know
that even if
theal is scrupulously kept by the
Iranians in every detail that they can
still that it's essentially gives them
permission to have nuclear weapons in 10
years because it all expires in 10 years
and then there is nothing no oversight
nothing prohibiting Iran from getting
nuclear weapons
then and of course it's very unlikely
that they're going to scrupulously keep
to the agreement and this is another
aspect of this that has been completely
overlooked and has not been part of the
discussion about it at all and that is
is Shiite Islam of course the Obama
Administration is bound as a matter of
policy to see no Islam hear no Islam
speak no Islam when it comes to Islam
but when it comes to the Islamic
Republic of Iran Islam is a very
important aspect of what it's all about
after all they call themselves the
Islamic Republic did you see Howard Dean
yesterday I don't consider the that Iran
is a Muslim
country well you know why he said that
it's not that he thinks full of
methodists he thinks that Islam is
wonderful and so if Iran is not
wonderful it must not be
Muslim he he he would call it the
misunderstands of Islam Republic of Iran
but in reality you can learn a lot about
Iran by looking into Islam one thing
that is in particular about Shiite Islam
in light of this nuclear deal is
especially
disquieting and since I'm so full of
good news today I'll bring you that too
the Islamic Republic of Iran is Shiite
it's the only major Shiite State it's
99% Shiite Shiites as I said are only 10
to 15% of Muslims worldwide and the
Islamic Republic of Iran that's it
that's the main Shiite entity in the
world by far now Shiite Islam being such
a minority among Muslims has a very
different it's it's almost exactly the
same in terms of their doctrines and
beliefs as Sunni Islam but it's it's a
very different tone a very different
attitude to be a Shiite as opposed to a
Sunni Shiites are uh very mournful and
very preoccupied with defeat and that's
because they have had nothing but defeat
in the book I have profiles of the 12
imams who are the founding figures of
Shiite Islam and every one of them you
can see well this guy he died in prison
and this one was poisoned by the sunnis
and these other ones were poisoned by
the sunnis as well and it's just it's a
long trail of misery and defeat because
they're a minority and because Islam
both both sides Sunni and Shiite they
both teach that apostates and Heretics
should be killed and because there's so
many more sunnis than Shia generally
it's the Shia who've been killed by the
sunnis so in response the Shiites
developed what is now a very famous
Concept in the west and that's
takya taka is
concealment if you wear a hat too it's
called a Taka it's that little cap skull
cap because uh it conceals your bald
spot
but tea is a particularly Shiite concept
it's and you you'll often hear Islamic
apologists say this when people talk
about tea in the west they'll say oh no
that's just a Shiite thing and we're
Sunni Muslim Brotherhood types well they
won't say that but we're sunnis and so
we never lie well the fact is that it's
based on the Quran which tells Muslims
in ch 3:28 to deceive unbelievers if
they're under pressure but tea
specifically really is a Shiite thing
that was developed so they would pretend
to be sunnis and avoid getting killed
and it's generally just that it's
religious deception that is sanctioned
in the Quran and widely practiced among
Shiites now what is most striking about
tea is that some of the lead some of
those imams particularly the sixth Imam
who was one of the foremost exponents of
Shiite theology
he explained that tea is not just
something that you do when the sunnis
come around to kill you tea he said it's
the center of our religion if you're not
practicing tea you're not a real
Muslim you have to be out there
deceiving that's what we're all
about now consider that you have tea
being Central in Shiite Islam being far
more important than people
realize and then you have an entire
State a nation a regime that is based on
Shiite Islam do you think that regime
might ever employ
deception do you think that the American
diplomats should have taken note of that
when they were in talks with the
Iranians about this nuclear
deal do you realize that we have been
paying for this nonsense paying for this
willful ignorance for decades now Jimmy
Carter it recently was revealed was the
recipient of a letter from the Ayatollah
Ki and Ki said he doesn't have to worry
this was before he took power he said
you don't have to worry if the Sha
leaves and the Islamic Republic comes in
then we will be as much of a friend of
the United States as the Sha was and Jim
Marda thought that was just
great and he said well then what we're
just going to betray the Sha and we'll
allow this Islamic Republic to come in
and he did it and he did it with several
of his advisers saying the AI he's a
religious man he's a holy man he's not
going to mislead us he's not going to
betray us really it's in the book I was
amazed when I found these quotes they
really thought they could deal with this
guy because you know Carter was very
religious and he just figured well this
is another one like
me and so here we
are now our best hope in all this is the
Iranian people who hate the regime and
what we need is a president who will
stand with them and make it very clear
that we will not tolerate the Islamic
Republic's Global adventurism and that
we will support the Iranian opposition
that Barack Obama stabbed in the back in
2009 and refused to support now
certainly that was just a protest over
an election and it's not clear that the
Islamic Republic itself would have
fallen if the opposition had succeeded
but there's no doubt that if we had
supported the opposition things could be
very different in the world today and we
probably wouldn't have this terrible
deal the Iranian people hate the regime
but they have nowhere to go nowhere to
turn it's very repressive and there is
it's not possible for them to express
opposition without being brutalized or
killed but if we were to support if we
were to stand up and say that we're not
going to tolerate the Islamic Republic
and we are actively supporting the
opposition there would be millions of
Iranians who that would resonate with
and you know don't know what would
happen I I'll I'll I know you're
supposed to open with a joke but I'm
going to close with one um the uh IAT Ki
is approached by a man and he says uh
Imam I want to blow myself up and go to
paradise because you know Paradise is
guaranteed in the Quran to Those Who
Kill and are killed and
so can you tell me what Paradise is like
and the Ayatollah said well it's always
perfect weather lots of trees the is
pure great place well can can you tell
me more what it's like specifically well
the it so the Ayatollah says that you
have the best food the finest meat
wonderful fruits everything anything you
want is available and the guy presses
him yet again so the Ayatollah says
okay think about this everybody gets
along everybody's happy everybody's got
a good
job everything's everything's beautiful
and so the guy once again he says really
I I can you give me anything more
specific and the Ayatollah says okay
it's like Iran under the
Sha that is a joke that actually
circulates widely in
Iran the Iranian people deserve better
than the Islamic Republic and so do we
and let's hope that we get it thank
you couple of quick questions uh first
can you talk a little bit about the role
of niak and uh I'm sorry the role of
what niak national
Iranian American Council yes and tiri
Pary and his role in making the deal
happen and second uh um what do we do
about air conditioning as John kery
thinks that's the most important
thing the national Iranian American
Council you recall uh that I was
speaking about how his Bala has sleeper
cells in the US but they're not striking
because they're getting what they want
without Terror attacks and suggested
that there were forces in Washington who
were uh influencing the administration
into thinking that this deal was a good
idea I did not name any names but
foremost among them is the national
Iranian American Council which is a
group that sort of like the Council on
American Islamic relations in that it
presents itself as one thing but it's
really another the national Iranian
American council is an arm of the
Islamic Republic it's been established
in court in federal court actually
actually because there were Iranian
dissidents in the US who who were saying
that nyak or the national Iranian
American
council is a front for the mulas and
they sued them for
Lial and they lost because they are a
front for the
mulas and they had to pay damages to
these Iranian dissonant because of uh
making these false
claims tra Pary is the head of the
national Iranian American Council he's
very influential in Washington and I'm
sure that he had a great deal to do with
convincing the administration that this
deal was a good thing also uh you may
know Rea aan who is a uh he was born in
Iran he's a very famous writer he wrote
a book about how Jesus was really a
revolutionary and another book about how
Muhammad was really a man of peace and
he uh is on all the shows he's a media
darling he actually is a board member of
the national Iranian American Council
which suggests that maybe the mullah are
orchestrating uh a lot of what we see
and what we hear about uh Islam and the
CH threat in general when these are the
people that the networks always go to
and they
nyak uh as far as the second question
goes uh the idea that air conditioners
and global warming are a uh greater
threat than the the Jihad well I just
don't know how many people my air
conditioner has be beheaded or uh or or
shot up in a nightclub but the it just
is a manifestation of the absolute
idiocy the willful ignorance of this
Administration that would be a joke if
it weren't so lethal and people are
getting killed as a result of it and
this uh is one of the best things I
think about the uh current political
climate is I think people really are
waking up to this in a way that they
weren't I was telling people outside
before we started that I'm much more
optimistic right now than I was on
August 2nd 2015 the brexit vote and
whatever you may think of him and this
is not an endorsement but the candidacy
of Donald Trump uh for all his faults
just the fact that he's so popular is an
expression of the fact that the people
are fed up and that they're fed up with
the political and media Elites and are
looking for somebody who will sweep all
that out and clean house I'm not sure
Trump will or that he will be able to
but just the fact of his candidacy is a
positive sign such that even if Hillary
wins
and works to throw away the freedom of
speech and all these other things there
will be a significant resistance
movement much more significant than I
would have thought last
year right
here yes sir Robert you mentioned the uh
reluctance of the administration to in
any way link terrorism with Islam even
though it seems that Islam is at war
with us uh they don't want to get people
to thinking that we're at war with Islam
and they said they don't want to offend
the moderates in Islam can you talk
about the moderates in Islam how how far
has Al CeCe president of Italy of of
Egypt gotten in his Reformation call how
far has Udi Asser in the United States
gotten with having a moderate Islam that
has full page ads all the time
denouncing Islamic terrorism I haven't
seen them that's a very good point uh
Barack Obama has said you remember when
Trump said that uh after after the
Orlando Massacre Trump said that uh
Obama was wrong not to mention radical
Islam now radical we could quibble with
because it's actually mainstream in
normative Islam but that's another story
even to go so far as to say radical
Islam is an improvement over what we've
got and Obama was angry you remember he
was he was livid and he said that uh
what difference would it make echoing
Hillary about Benghazi would it uh win
us allies would help us with a new
strategy and he dismissed all
that and he said that we cannot validate
these people that Al-Qaeda and Isis they
claim to be Muslim and we cannot give
them that
validation now I ask you if you are a
member of no you're a Muslim and you're
thinking about joining Isis and you're
reading the Quran and seeing it tell
tells you to wage war against infidels
and so on but then you see John KY says
they're not Islamic you going to think
oh I was going to join Isis but but John
krey said they're not Muslim so I've
decided to get a job at McDonald's
instead it's absolutely absurd Muslims
look to Muslim clerics to tell them what
Islam is about and they look to the
Quran and the example of Muhammad to
tell them what Islam is about they don't
look to non-muslim political leaders to
tell them what Islam is about so in the
first place the premise is completely
ludicrous
now the problem with it is that it of
course hamstrings our ability to De
defeat this enemy because we keep
misdiagnosing the problem and so we
cannot employ the proper Solutions in
reality getting to the uh the other part
of your question the moderates the
moderates they're great I love them but
they're not doing any good CCE called
several years ago for a widespread
re-evaluation of the Islamic texts he
said it before all the clerics at Alazar
which is the foremost institution in
Sunni Islam
and that he asked them to come up with
ways so that Islam was not a Wellspring
of violence and terrorism and these
texts would not incite people to commit
these acts of violence that was a couple
years ago nothing's happened zudi jasser
is a real nice guy and he's been out
there for years now and he still has
more non-muslims in his group than
Muslims and only a handful of Muslims in
his group a few hundred I think last I
heard right aside from personalities
just one one other thing there was a
Muslims against Isis rally in Washington
DC not long ago 50 Muslims showed up do
you know how many Muslims showed up
after the massacre of the Charlie ABDO
cartoonists in Chia there was a rally
not against the massacre but against the
cartoonists 800,000 showed up for that
so this shows you the power of the
moderates the problem is that normative
mainstream Islam teaches violence and
hatred teaches Warfare against and
subjugation of unbelievers that's a an
unpleasant fact but it's a readily
demonstrable fact and as long as we
ignore it it's not going to go away
it'll just keep advancing and to pretend
that it's not the case will not make it
go away the only thing we can do is
speak honestly about it and then try to
formulate ways to deal with it but we
can't do that if we don't even admit
that it exists as a
problem right here okay yes sir yes um
Robert I just want to uh
thank you so much and may God give you
continue to give you strength thank you
um I wanted I was going to talk about
zudi jasser and is it a positive or
negative and to me unless the only way
to reform Islam is to expunge Muhammad
and the Quran from it but that seems
unrealistic um the it just seems the
difficulty now
is everybody says we're not at war with
Islam isn't it about time to say we are
at war with Islam it is an evil religion
and the and Will are there a billion
Muslims who will defend Islam or are
there billion slaves that would welcome
such a message ah there's the key right
there you hit on
it how about this this is a little bit
different what if we had gone into Iraq
and Afghanistan and said we're the
United States of America and this is our
constitution these are the principles
we're standing for you know we didn't do
that what we did in Iraq and Afghanistan
was go in and install Sharia
constitutions constitutions in both
countries that said Islamic law is the
law of the
land now what's the point of that that
would have been like going into Germany
after Hitler was dead and making himler
the the the new
furer it's it's it's
ridiculous the the fact is that Sharia
is the cause of all this but see we
don't admit that to ourselves and so we
can't do anything about it the teachings
of Islamic law regarding Warfare against
unbelievers are right Central in Islamic
law so if we install Islamic law in Iraq
and Afghanistan we're only going to
exacerbate the problem that got us there
in the first place what we should have
done was say if you are a woman who's
being beaten by your husband because the
Quran says to beat a disobedient wife we
will give you shelter if you are a
non-muslim who is being persecuted
because you're a non-muslim and you
can't get a good job or you can't can't
get a decent place to live we will take
care of you if you are brutalized or
victimized because of Islamic law you
will find Refuge with the American
troops do you think any Muslims would
have responded to that I do I think the
people would have responded to that in
droves because while Islamic law people
always conflate Islam and Muslims and
that's why they say that I'm anti-muslim
because I speak about Islam critically
but actually I'm very PR Muslim I want
them to be freed from Islam
I want the these people not to live with
this violence and oppression and I know
that there are many Muslims who don't
want to live with this violence and
oppression but they can't get out it's
it's a it's a room with no exit door
they'll kill you if you leave so we say
also if anybody wants to leave Islam and
they are threatened with death they can
find Refuge if we had done that the
world would be a very different place
and we would have massive support in
every Muslim country I don't know if we
can declare war on Islam as such because
it's a it's an set of ideas and I'm very
much afraid of making war on I mean we
should combat bad ideas but I don't want
to restrict any I don't want to have any
restrictions on speech and that's what
that would involve the the the F
fundamental Cornerstone of a free
Society is the freedom of speech in the
United States we don't Outlaw ideas
because that leads to having thought
police and thought crimes and that's how
the left plays the game that's what
we're heading for now in the other
direction I don't want to Outlaw Islam I
want to defeat the Jihad which I believe
that we can do if we speak about it
honestly and stand up for our own
principles but nobody is suggesting
doing that nobody I don't why why can't
we have even one politician who's saying
I don't understand it but in any case I
think that uh recognizing certainly that
Islam is at war with us we can do
and understanding a sedition
a great deal of the Sharia advancement
in the United States and the attempts to
uh impose Islamic law and aspects of
Islamic law over American law all that
should be done and more right here
Robert yeah I have two questions
one uh do we monitor any of the
suspected mosques or they believe that
the Iman is preaching terrorism no
I'll tell you a story very briefly
Islamic Society of
Boston Islamic Society of Boston was
attended by the tarv brothers who did
the Boston Marathon Jihad bombing it was
also attended by afia sadiki who is
doing 86 years for trying to kill
American soldiers for Al-Qaeda it was
also attended by TK Mahana 17 years for
aiding Al-Qaeda it was also attended by
akmed Abu Samra who is responsible for
the uh Islamic State very sophisticated
social media presence he was their Tech
guy or their their uh Twitter whatever
anyway all those people went there it
was founded by abdur Rahman Alam mudi
who is now doing 23 years for financing
Al-Qaeda now that place is obviously a
hot bed of jihad training Jihad
recruiting it's it's clear it's not just
one person it's many so right after the
Boston Marathon bombing uh our friend
Congressman Lou gomert uh from Texas he
was grilling the FBI director then it
was Robert Mueller and he asked him had
you ever been to the Islamic Society of
Boston and Mueller uh he was meeting the
FBI not Mueller in person and uh Mueller
was very indignantly said yes of course
for
outreach now you know what that means
that means that the only time they went
to the Islamic Society of Boston was not
to investigate it was to reassure the
Muslims there that the FBI was not
islamophobic
so that's where we are with monitoring
mosques you had a second yeah the second
question is uh according to Governor
Christie of New Jersey in the dead of
night UPS planes brought in many Muslims
and deposited them in various areas
around New Jersey is that true I never
heard that I never heard christe saying
that I really don't know what that's all
about Christie I know is very close to
Muslim Brotherhood elements in New
Jersey and has dismissed missed concern
about Sharia encroachment in the US as
crap so I don't really uh credit
Christie for being very alert on this
issue but I don't know the S the
incident you're referring to so I can't
say anything about it right here uh yes
sir I in in a Fox
News I heard and I saw a a US retired
General I don't remember his name who
said that it's very easy to get rid of
Isis by bombing even with nuclear
weapons before they get I'd like to know
your opinion about
it well I would I think it can be done
without nuclear weapons I don't think
that we can defeat Isis with ground
troops and I don't think we can defeat
Isis with the current situation where
we're making some air strikes that are
essentially Cosmetic in nature and not
effective meanwhile you know who is
defeating Isis it's Iran and John said
uh Iran's being very helpful with us for
us against Isis as if if Iran takes over
that span of land there's going it's
going to be good for the United States
it's it's ridiculous what we need is to
go back in with ground troops this is uh
something I say with great reluctance
because the last one was botched so
badly in part by what we were discussing
before that the mission was all wrongly
conceived and we didn't stand up for our
own principles so we need to not make
the mistakes from before as a matter of
fact I don't think we need to engage in
any nation building at all or try to
supervise their elections or set up
their next government just go in and get
rid of Isis and then they let them sort
it out it will set back the global Jihad
Movement by
decades go in get rid of them and get
out will they will there still be
jihadis of course will they form some
other Jihad State possibly probably even
but this state of Isis the Islamic State
it's a very potent thing because they
claim to be the caliphate the caliphate
in Sunni Islam is the only legitimate
government for Muslims worldwide and
that idea is so powerful that they
attracted 30,000 foreign fighters from
all over the world to go there from 100
countries to go to Iraq and Syria they
have active branches in 18
countries and they are still recruiting
Americans just today there was news of a
Washington DC metr trans officer the
first law enforcement official to become
a member of Isis or to
try and it's because of this concept of
the caliphate that makes Muslims all
around the world think that they have to
do its bidding and so if we were to
destroy the
califate that would be extraordinary
that would be an incredible Victory last
year I in my book The Complete infidels
guide to Isis I showed that the uh split
between Isis and Al-Qaeda came Isis used
to be al-Qaeda in Iraq and Isis and
Al-Qaeda split because the Isis faction
wanted to establish the caliphate and
the al-Qaeda group Osama Bin Laden at
the time and Iman Al zawahiri They said
no it's not a good time the Americans
will smash the caliphate if you set it
up now well so far Isis has been proven
right but if we did go ahead and make
Al-Qaeda right and smash the caliphate
that would that would be a tremendous
blow to the global Jihad and it has to
be done and it should be done with
ground it can only be done with ground
troops try to get have maybe time for
one or two more okay I'll try to be less
loquacious hi Robert hello um I'm such a
fan that I dragged my husband to hear
you and it's working because he's taking
two pages of notes thank
you I have a question about what is good
about uh
Islam I understand it's very seductive
and even FBI agents are seduced by it um
but if you take away Sharia law and
Muhammad out of the Quran what is left
that is good you can't take Muhammad and
Sharia out of Islam that would be like
taking the pope and Holy Communion out
of Catholicism you can't take the Torah
out of Judaism it would it's the same
thing and um Islam is Muhammad what
Muhammad said and did and what the Quran
says that's what it's all based on now
what's good in
it there's a there's a kind of a folk
religion that's not strictly speaking
Islam by the book that prevails in many
parts of the world or has prevailed up
until the Saudis have bankrolled its
destruction and its replacement by the
uh more virent and violent form that
they favor but for example if you were
to go in the 1970s or the 1960s to
Mogadishu which which is a hell hole now
but if you were to go there you would
find people who were Muslims who would
be very kind to you and they would tell
you that they were being kind to you
because of Islam and I've met Muslims
who actually think particularly somalis
but also from all over the world and
they they're not very educated in Islam
itself and they seem to think that being
nice being kind being charitable to
other people is a is a is a specifically
Islamic concept
and so they they think that they have
this kind of a of a vague folk religion
that is Islamic in character but which
makes them behave better than they might
have otherwise no that's that's that's a
fact but the problem is that when they
start actually reading the book the book
is so full of hate and so full of
exhortations to violence that the more
devout and knowledgeable they get in the
religion the worse people they're likely
to
be and this is the problem that we have
to confront it does no good to sugarcoat
it we're going to have to make the last
question one more one more yes um I just
in retrospect I think that we must
uh understand and forgive ex-president
Carter because in the welcoming of keni
he he was a little mixed up and he
thought it was the second coming of
[Music]
Christ anyway my question is this um we
have police departments begging the uh
Muslim uh communities please let us know
if you see unusual activity so we can
you know not have another Massacre and
yet the response has been very very
little hardly at all so I'm wondering is
are they afraid of the um repulsion of
their of the um people around them the
Muslims or is there something in the
Quran that says you don't snitch on
other uh Muslims and or anything
negative about them yes chapter 4: 92 of
the Quran says don't kill other Muslims
and by
extension in Islamic theology you really
are not to act in any negative way
against other Muslims there is a very
strong dichotomy in Islam between the
Muslims and the non-muslims that really
characterizes all of Islam it's all
about that dichotomy chapter 48: 29 of
the Quran says muhammmad is the Apostle
of Allah those who follow him are
merciful to one another but ruthless to
the
unbelievers and so if the unbelievers
are saying if you see something say
something please help us uh the the the
Believers are going to say no I can't I
won't because they are Muslims and
you're not they're not going to say that
to their faces but that's how they will
act and so you have uh Trump again
recently he he uh in his big foreign
policy speech that he gave right after
the Orlando shooting he said that the
Muslim communities have to help us with
h with this implying that they weren't
which was absolutely true and Ibrahim
Hooper of the Council on American
Islamic relations was on television the
next night denouncing Trump and saying
uh of course we what does he mean we we
always give help to law enforcement now
this guy is the spokesman for an
organization that hands out pamphlets at
its conferences that say don't talk to
the
FBI and uh the one of them is um what to
do when the FBI knocks on your door with
a picture of somebody going
sh and I have photographs of these
pamphlets that were taken by friends in
the care
conferences and then he goes on
television and says they always
cooperate they tell people not to
cooperate with law enforcement and as a
matter of fact it's very rare that you
find Muslims actually revealing a terror
plot before it happens after it happens
they all say oh yes I I if if if they're
if it's undeniable that they knew the
man then they say well I tried to talk
him out of it or something like that but
they never called the cops and of course
the reason for that is the primary
loyalty is to the Muslims and also
because of all the violence and hatred
in the Quran even if somebody is never
going to blow himself up or shoot people
him self he's not necessarily against
other people doing
it thank you thank you very much